holy sentiments is the heading Anna what
I quickly review with you that when it
comes to an event that has more than one
stage or one component to it for
instance you know someone loose the coin
three times that's not three stages each
coin flip is its own stage but we
consider everything together when it
comes to multistage events it's really
only one question that needs to be
fundamentally answered which is when you
combine sin stages together and I'll
answer whatever question it is that we
are being asked do you add the
probabilities or do you multiply the
probabilities or what combination about
your third do you do so let's actually
do that example I just said um three
coin tosses if we represent this
diagrammatically and quick question for
you what do you think would be the
diagram of choice you've got a few too
strong if you were doing three coin
flips in there were any submissions yeah
the tree diagram is the way to go doc
diagrams are often pretty useful once
you get that third stage you're like
where's it where's it going with the
third thing going to go okay you want a
three-dimensional diagram that we paint
so let's all quickly destroy the tree
diagram which would correspond to three
successive coin flips so for instance
you got first set where you can either
land a head or a tail and then you're
going to get this happening well you've
got it happen again right after you
first flip
your second flip is going to look is
going to be it's gonna look exactly the
same except it wouldn't happen again
based on whether you're a head or a tail
and it just kind of keeps on breaking
you up right now we've got one of these
two coefficients so I need my third set
which is why sorry I told you this is
why I was being a bit lazy let me see if
I still line up nicely
I bet it was I'll try I've got now my
third set yeah oh yeah that works
yeah a big place in this okay now you
can see what our final sample space is
here over on the right-hand side yeah
I've got one two three four five six
seven eight
turtle outcomes at the end it should be
surprising because each time in specific
bifurcates so you've got two two squared
two cute that's why you've got Nate's
turtle possibilities now this is a tree
diagram it's not a probability tree
diagram because I haven't labeled any of
the branches with their actual values
can anyone tell me why in this case it's
probably all with it why is it not worth
actually labeling with the individual
probabilities in this case
okay one other one you know the cap the
numbers again is quite easy isn't that
nice and personal
okay so this room right so not only have
you got fairly simple numbers to work
with
I would say if you had numbers on here
by the way they're all just going to be
a half in this case right don't give up
on your hanging information which
doesn't actually get you toward solving
the question to do it so I'm just going
to leave it as it is now what will be
the probability of well let me give you
a particular example what would be the
probability of flipping the same sign
I'm not going to say which side if
they'd be the same side three times all
the times in a row what will be the
probability of them to the same side all
three times in a row
well the first thing we'll do is we can
say on this diagram I can highlight the
plus which satisfied the conditions that
I want right so brings up one here here
and head head there you go that's one of
them that will meet the requirements and
I didn't specify which face which side
so I could also have do you have a good
tail tail tail there we go
so I'm going to work out the properties
of each of those and then 18 could both
of them so now when I say I'll write
just the ones that are relevant for me
ha ha ha in what way addition to
multiplication that we're going to get
am I going to combine these
probabilities to get this probability at
the end yeah when I go from left to
right across my own probabilities ready
across my tree diagram I should say I
will multiply so I'm gonna just to make
that really obvious and for all of you
I'd like you to do the same even though
of course if you go when 1/2 times 1/2
is equal to I want to write that down
just to communicate you where my answer
which of course is 1/8 where it comes
from
ok so going from left to right I am
multiplying
but then would I have a look at this guy
down to which naturally has exactly the
same probability
I now have these two numbers a name and
an a in this case they are the same
because everything is equal chance but
of course they don't have to be in a
different situation how am I going to
combine these two probabilities together
will I use addition or multiplication
in this case I'm going to add them so
when I add an a that gives me the actual
probability that I want which is quarter
now I use this as a very simple example
because it's so intuitive and the
numbers so easy and work that you
yourself can clearly see why it must be
addition one way and multi-patient the
other for instance suppose I got mixed
up in my head and I thought oh do I do I
add as I go from left to right well if
you think about that first one we're
trying to work out is 3 1 up here what's
the probability of flipping heads 3
times in a row you quickly get something
nonsensical if you confuse which one is
which if you try to add note then when
you add you get 1/2 plus 1/2 plus 1/2
it's like oh wow I haven't 150 percent
chance of flipping heads three times in
a row something is part of the pun not
adding up so you can see if you're ever
uncertain about whether it's additional
multiplication then think about an
example which is easy for you to work
with and it's it's obvious to you which
one is going to be and when so
frequently a multi-stage win so you're
gonna have to use both addition and
multiplication and you just need to know
when so that make sense